hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play and the
story no we are in basement of sorts
what am i doing what am i doing what am
i doing where am I going oh yeah I need
to get the other component of this AHA
and it's down here
question mark let's like this please
thank you we have this plenty I got
plenty sleep is only one thank you
now slice some of these two I'm actually
going to I've said base in just about
every custom story I play I'm gonna end
this custom story with zero tinderbox
left I'm actually gonna use them like
for realsies opium I can't do it man try
to quit oh I had a physically something
something was gonna happen
alright okay tinderbox turning the box
was there anything else in here besides
that probably not good made Piggy's
sorry thank you feels so jumpy okay
there's nothing all right I guess I was
it man i i i lied all the torches and
still like nothing's pitch blackness
all right I don't like this I don't like
this this is not good I can tell when
something's not good glycerol the other
component in nitroglycerin and note ii
of july 1829 upon further
experimentation with chemical mixtures i
have discovered the violent explosive
effects of the compound nitroglycerin
quite by accident i combined a mixture
of nitric acid and glycerol and set it
somewhere in the cellar on its own the
compound is relatively safe however when
jostled are struck with an object the
combination suddenly becomes violent and
destructive
I nearly caved in the entire our wine
cellar figuring that one out extreme
care must be taken when mixing and
handling these chemicals if mishandled
death and destruction will surely ensue
sounds like fun to me I like those two
things I don't like down here
now what am I supposed to blow up that's
the question I think I'm looking for
this Emma's father's real lab or lab or
why no ha ha which way is it going its
way he's going which way is he going
which way is he going oh he's right
there
what down boost man I mean come on gotta
give me more warning than that oh man oh
God
all right boys man you just carry on
your way and I'll slip around I'm
assuming that he's going in a circle
oh yeah yes creaky creepy alright don't
mind me buddy not mind me buddy
[Applause]
[Music]
no going going
what am i doing wait a minute wait a
minute what am i doing blown up this I'm
a load of this hey put it yeah yeah
uh-huh
rocks yeah yeah always not chasing me
anymore oh-ho you son of a [ __ ] okay
Oh three points BAM right on it I'm the
boss lag about kapu Oh get out of your
best man
oh okay he must have been scripted
something to follow me oh I can't their
events what the hell is going on down
there yeah maybe not what find that out
you've been living here for how long
since your father disappeared and you're
just now thinking like wait a spider
spider spider presen the day kept
getting weirder and weirder really you
describe it as weird I didn't think it
could get any darker than that wine
cellar God good was I wrong sorry I
forgot to do my Emma voice oh yeah this
looks Pleasant my last one okay go oh
this is dandy
Oh always good when it starts off with
body parts chair bones spread feel law
the island sorry Haven is there anything
in there
I don't think though I think there was
not bucket
Scrabble up a little level live a little
I knew that let's go trouble block on
their store people log on this door
appears to be rusted and very wine but
it won't break with my bare hands no
matter how much killer and BP I am as a
woman if they're a tool I can use
because if you've got Emma is a
bodybuilding chicken I decided this cuz
everyone knows that's my type
Oh a dead guy Oh some bones I guess I
also a dead guy I suppose you call it so
I'm not gonna waste that there well
where did all these noises come from
they everyone seems to be dead around
here I know I saw the no I saw the note
stop screaming at me to go back to you
know Oh what if I don't really know oh
okay I don't know what day it is for the
year I can't even remember how long have
been in this horrible place I think they
put something in the water
they put something water to make you
forget everything always seems fuzzy
maybe it's better that I don't remember
what they're doing to us down here every
day I find some new wound on my body
I also feel strange as if they are
trying out some new kind of crazy drugs
on us if I ever skip this place I swear
to god I'll seek revenge on them all
especially Robert for doing this to me
Alexander Alexander a Dante's ah ok it
sounds like it's stuff that they were
doing in the original Indonesia
you know torturing people for their hit
a and then making them forget them so
that they can make them afraid again or
fear
what is that what is that oh hey binder
Huh What Huh What huh what oh no no
really you're gonna have those long
boxes they're not have something keyword
good yeah nope nothing down there no I
don't think huh ha ha what what what
broke wow it's a body oh I get it a body
was supposed to pop out of those boxes I
ruined that I ruined that okay there's
gender box okay dark trying to conserve
some oil okay okay oh really really now
you're gonna show me that I just got a
friend oh man does that the notification
buzz oh you got a friend
Oh shoulda known something like that was
gonna happen whoa hey Oh missed me we're
gonna do now Oh hot stuff so I thought
gimme yeah
yeah okay you go down this way
no yes yes yes it's not gonna move don't
think I wanted to either like totally
shut up ah ha ha I found this secret
well probably not a secret pie exactly
where I'm supposed to be oh no oh no oh
no my least favorite place my least
favorite place of all places to be is
here this is my absolutely favorite
place please favorite least favorite
18:44 I'm not sure how long I've been in
this horrible place but I'm certain it
is still 1844 I tried to dig my way out
using the chipper I found but if you're
I cannot go any further I lost yet
another Cavin and this time it caused a
mortal wound I've not the strength to
keep on digging
it has wonder how I even got this far
god I don't know what happened one day
I'm working for Robert making keys and
helping out in experiments then he finds
that cursed orb and everything changed
his personality underwent a radical
transformation and soon I did not even
recognize the man I'd known for years
many years he threw me down here in this
damn cell there cell we were keeping my
specimens for experimentation yeah the
whole damn team throw down here
it didn't take long the prisoners long
to rip us apart
it didn't take the prisoners long to rip
us apart
luckily my cell mates were shackled to
the wall allowing me to attempt to
escape whoever finds this no know that I
was always loyal to Robert something was
seven it has to do with that all
whatever cost you must destroy the
damned object and hand all this before
it gets any worse I just hope he won't
interfere with you I'm this chipper
brings you more luck than his former
holder I can't be with you
Braxton Archer that's a guy from the
note before okay okay okay all right
don't like this place don't like it
don't like it don't like it 100 you're
just a roach Oh
oh my now is not the time for silliness
leg protect me leg stop it stop it
stop it stop it stop it I got a hammer I
remember when I got a hammer donk dink
bigger damn did they break I still have
that doesn't say jack doodlee you're a
lie oh oh get away get away get away get
away get away get away get away get away
get away hide behind behind behind
behind me Jaime Jaime Jaime hobby Oh
bodies always buy the wrong choice
oh this was the wrong choice oh this was
so wrong oh here we here Jaime Oh get
out of here body parts ok go over there
oh I'm losing it
I'm losing it I'm losing it I'm losing
it I'm losing it my brain can't handle
the stress
is he not coming in after me ah ah I
know I know I know no no no no no it's
bad okay
stand in the light you all your
breathing is often we masculine Emma she
knows how to breathe like a man yeah how
do you imagine a big Russian female
bodybuilding for some stranger's darts
to be done yeah darling okay yeah oh
actually I'm all out of sign hi thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotations for other videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye